it is really all falling off the walls
for Donald Trump and the growing body of
knowledge about contact with Russian
officials during the presidential
campaign and before I jump into any of
this let me reset the stage for you have
any of the allegations or claims made
about Donald Trump in Russia been found
to be untrue so far I'm having a hard
time thinking of any Russia hacked to
help Trump win we know now that that is
indeed the case Michael Flynn talked
sanctions with the Russian ambassador
before being confirmed as the national
security adviser that ended up being
true Trump had a plan to remove
sanctions on Russia the New York Times
story I told you about yesterday said
indeed that is true that Michael Cohen
Trump's personal lawyer hand-delivered
it to former national security adviser
Michael Flynn the Russian dossier Trump
said it didn't exist it's been confirmed
that it does Trump said the contents are
all fake it's now been confirmed that
some of the contents are true the Trump
team and Russian officials were indeed
in touch during the lead-up to the
election that's now been confirmed true
by intercepted communications from US
agencies some people are writing to me
saying but David that's just one source
and like Donald Trump I also don't trust
our own intelligence agencies what about
Russian sources confirming this and we
do indeed have that as well Donald
Trump's claims have been nobody on my
team had any contact with Russian
authorities during the campaign Kremlin
officials have admitted that they were
in touch with members of Donald Trump
staff he is repeatedly denied it and we
know indeed that it is true two days
after Donald Trump's election victory
the Russian Deputy Foreign Minister
Sergei Ryabkov Ribe qov I'm not exactly
sure how the last name is pronounced
said that the Russian government had
been in touch with Trump's advisers
during the campaign and now earlier this
month the Russian ambassador to the u.s.
said I was in frequent contact during
the campaign with Michael Flynn we
learned of core
in the forced resignation of Michael
Flynn that they were in touch after
Election Day but before inauguration day
pad and now that same Russian ambassador
it's no longer just US intelligence says
oh yeah we were in touch before the
election I mean it seems like just about
every week now a new aspect to the story
is being confirmed yeah and yes there
are many things from this story that he
could kind of survive politically like
Russia wanted to help him win the
election maybe that doesn't fall on him
or the fact that his team was in contact
with Russians I mean maybe they weren't
aware that they were undercover
operatives but if a bombshell comes out
that they were colluding together he
can't survive that right you're sort of
hypothesizing ways in which the letter
of this could be true but it doesn't
have wide-ranging political implications
but again most of those scenarios we
know not to be true and the Russian
ambassador to the US Sergei kis lyac has
now said oh I was in touch with Michael
Flynn we were speaking on the phone in
person we would be texting etc etc is
there any doubt at this point I mean the
one entity denying this now is the Trump
team which has lied all along we have
u.s. intelligence plus Russian officials
saying yes they were in touch we have a
resignation that took place Michael
Flynn's after having lied about his
discussions with Russia I don't know how
anybody can doubt this now and people
email me every once in a while Pat and
they say listen David
there's hysteria about Russia what
really matters is the content of what
Russia hacked the hacking at this point
is a tiny piece of this yes the the
hacking that maybe was meant to help
Trump win or maybe you don't believe
that and you don't care about how it was
leaked but the content that now is such
a small piece of this but that's not
even really a defense of anything the
information that was hacked that was
important but not so much now because
we're months removed from the campaign
and yes I mean the revelations we got
from Hillary Clinton that was important
but I mean if they were just playing one
side over another that just goes against
the legitimacy of our election would you
say at this point that the Russians are
lying to us less than Donald Trump is in
some sense at least with regard to this
issue I'm getting the feeling that that
the case I mean I think they're lying
just about the same amount oh yeah I
guess a trump is lied publicly about
this multiple times trump is working
very very hard to push the narrative
that the only truth there is is what you
personally hear from Donald Trump
it's obviously absurd at face value but
what's horrifying and frightening and
scary is that many people are believing
that and are taking that approach and
this combined with Trump's attacks on
media Trump's leg the media is the enemy
of the people and that's rhetoric that
that is reminiscent of many
authoritarian pre dictatorial moments in
the in history over the last couple of
hundred years we could laugh it off pat
if it weren't for the fact that so many
people are believing this stuff and then
they see media and they're instantly
distrustful at the sort of systemic
fundamental level skepticism healthy
skepticism about what you are getting
from corporate media from any media is
obviously important and a relevant part
of media literacy but jumping onboard
the Trump train that media is the enemy
of the people you can only believe what
I say in the context of much of what he
said being being debunked as lies that's
very dangerous and millions of people
buy it and in the same way you have to
be skeptical of the media you also have
to be skeptical of the people in power
and Trump is the president United States
you have to be even if you support them
even if you're a Republican you have to
call it out when you see it and a lot of
these trumpets have an internal
rationalization which is okay yeah
normal politicians I would distrust but
Trump is different he's not
establishment he's draining the swamp
blah blah blah every single one of those
campaign talking points has been
debunked Trump filled the swamp he
didn't drain it the day he started
announcing who his cabinet picks were
going to be every single one of these
sort of outsider non-establishment
talking points we now know to be untrue
but again it was effective in priming is
is the the sort of term that's used when
you want to influence thought in a less
than completely over way the trumpets
have been very successfully primed to do
exactly what it is that they are doing
right now